how's it going bros my name is peter pan
welcome back at Dwight and night I
wasn't actually gonna play this cuz it's
it's long as long as hell
Azrael it's really long but I changed my
mind because there were so many people
begging me to do it so I guess I have to
what no it's actually one of the most
expect like asks for know whatever this
is play it's goes to Denver State
Hospital
and it's like remembering instead of
loading that's as fancy because
apparently you've forgotten stuff about
staff I forget stuff I'm really bad
remember stuff
I think stuff I think at least I mean I
don't remember huh hey Sonia
no Thomas I you that why do they have
time that's freaking and but I don't
know this seems really unnecessary for
me but let's just watch it anyway
white knight and amnesia Dark Descent
what I was pretty sure about that one
before ever
okay okay where's the father David try
not to be late okay I will don't worry I
haven't forgotten
good forgotten the BJ our anniversary
and that's it that means be super impose
acting I feel bad for him to have a
girlfriend themselves like that okay
wait what am i doing on the floor guys
skip this no Brenda not my budget
psychiatrist oh I like boys actors for
today
music it's been three years of course I
do crazy you can't forget
Thanks
come on
come on show me something this should I
good I mean bad - ear the ass yeah that
makes sense I mean a fridge naked guy
and yeah that makes sense to anything
definite that doesn't make sense
okay not sure we're gonna cook there's a
lot right now cuz it's really oh wait I
can move holy [ __ ] haha am i doing her
gives me their I don't what is going in
I don't understand
what am I doing here how do I get out
okay we're good
I will go up a heart this is where the
loading screens it's never good
I don't trust corridors but is going on
here while they are who today's I don't
trust I don't trust anything okay let's
go ahead okay it's pretty good
I don't even know any boy okay better
penis monster want to married me
huh
man I'm sick tree that's sick sick the
heck is going on it
okay
ma don't blow me away Oh
okay I can deal with this for now it's
like it this is weird but the heck is
going on
I like this about it now actually
they're both pretty
okay I get it I get it
the [ __ ] is going on
as I work as I book I was wondering no I
was something I didn't know yet cement
familiar I felt like being here before
but I couldn't recall any memory of I
always get to that boy somehow I don't
even know worst part it I can't recall
any memories of mine it is like I'm
living a nightmarish Ida gala Wow
okay get up get up
oh good I can read that huh perfect
all right free nice random I got Locker
pretty clean too you know the Florida
pretty nice
so yeah this mod is like a mixture of
amnesia and a number of pretty much you
don't remember anything do you David ha
I bet you don't don't yet won't I can't
breathe but please they would have me
for once and I think about me I want to
get out of here nevertheless I can't
promise you that you won't be seeing
diapers again one last thing be careful
about stuff I hate stuff I don't stop
okay can't go that high Thank You kid go
though okay yeah nothing in there great
so yeah no I'm not David
nah man what am i doing hello David
how are you today pretty [ __ ] I don't
know am i sitting on this am i I'm
thinking oh there's a person they holy
crap I'm your doctor doctor Sofia ah and
you're in the hospital a mental one do
you remember that no no
don't worry David it's not on this Pekka
to freak out things in your condition
and that's why I'm here to help you
are you ready for our session today
David
why am I alone here
because you are a criminal patient David
supergirl not a criminal I am here to
heal your mom good good you better be
better I know what that means
I know what that means thank god I've
got here
unzip happy I don't trust this damn I
don't trust this what the heck was that
hello what where I love I just grabbed a
truck what is he doing
um man okay I guess we gotta go here and
stuff like I really don't want to go
here
oh man
public showers never good idea I better
look lock the doors or the penis Matsuri
wanna shower with me and stuff like that
that's never good this is a puzzle
it seems like a puzzle hey muscles man
okay that's a green one and oh man if
you see okay uh yes
okay we're good huh perfect that's stuck
okay
blood perfect it's stuck all right you
all right huh
okay what do I do us is through our
forever huh okay all right I come uh I
mean I'm are they even changed interface
they changed a lot of things in you what
are you doing your corner now I are they
really really tired out I'm gonna eat ya
next we gotta poop on you know I mean
eat you actually gotta poop I don't I
don't what did okay whatever you're
lucky you're lucky - stuck oh I
shouldn't have but don't run away okay
stuck
ah good good I got there it's your lucky
day mr. Mouse you on the straw you got
the straw you got the long straw now
Miss Mary wrap okay let's just pretend
it died cuz I feel better than why is
there a ladder in the frickin shower
I'll ever know
oh man I don't trust this I don't trust
this oh wait we did this in penumbra you
just pull this here perfect perfect I'm
a genius afro
what are you doing everything else
didn't I tell you a minute ago oh man
mister she'll do this for me
right ha creating a man shut up mister
Sharon where I see wait oh whatever
okay why no one lets me live in my very
own world are they jealous of me or
simply I'm a threat to community
I can understand my family my friends
want to heal but why would I go back in
life full of misery I'm afraid they will
make me forget everything I thought
doctors were trying to help me
that's that kid what do you think this
is sheriff I don't know well I got a
light doctor they're pretty nice they
gave me a lot of tops Sheriff
but seriously though we need to get the
hell out of here they think we're crazy
what you crazy
no you're not crazy why would you look
crazy make no sense I mean I was sure
I'm your buddy you can trust me I know I
don't trust the doctors dr. Sam crazy
don't worry about me we'll get heck out
of here and then we'll have strawberry
lemonade mmm sounds very good mr.
Sheriff
sounds very good mr. Jack I know I'll
make it myself like I'll make you're the
one I know you like it with a straw and
you know yeah
we're through Liam I don't know it's not
my fault mr. Sherr I don't don't hit me
please pity I know you like doing that
but put it down okay I'll try
I don't know seriously though voice I
need to find a key there's some ways he
shares
hello okay now shut up I'll be a panda
man okay okay I have do many voices it
well hey pretty dope TV alright the [ __ ]
is where's the key
I mean it's gotta be here somewhere
come on it's got to be there somewhere
I know y'all mr. shares and [ __ ] but
maybe under the breath you [ __ ] on their
breath alright
wait what the heck is this mushroom yeah
I hate mushroom mushroom really I meant
tomato wow I'm really [ __ ] sometimes
alright maybe it's here I don't even
know anymore
no it's oh no its patient continues
occasionally lose some parts of his
memories especially wants about the
incident this is unexpected as is rate
not expected and stuff goddamn late
stuffing got damn you're sexy Mentos
holy crap okay okay
Marzuki guess I won't tell me where the
key is what is this
morphine perfect perfect
alright come on key no what are you
doing
I don't want to be patient I want to be
major are you [ __ ] kidding me
be patient suck my dick